So guys it's time for the most up Instagram posts of
the week.
Oh, I forgot about that.
This one's great. Uh, actually,
it's very kind of weird and
someone sent this to me. I'm not going to say the name, obviously,
cause I don't want to out her. I just, this,
I haven't done fo most up Instagram posted a week and a long time.
I am bringing it back because of this one. This is how crazy this one is. Okay.
A girl's on a Vesper almost. You guessed it showing her.
Cause the skirts coming up, if it was up an inch higher,
you'd see her back door hole. Okay.
And that's a serious thing here. So she says,
apparently she just got 1 million followers. All right.
That's what she's saying. 1 million of you right now.
I'm looking back on this time. Last year.
When I used to write in my little work notebook, quote,
1 million followers on Instagram,
I would trace that over and over while Incapsula here.
Literally crying because I wanted it so bad.
Now let's just take a second to imagine
a 20 year old girl in a coffee shop
tracing over 1 million followers
crying. Hey,
go home. Hey,
why do you have a
pencil period?
You know here either. This is true.
And you are literally Jeffrey
Dahmer, only a serial killer traces words over and over again.
You know that nobody has ever even traced over
more than one letter that hasn't killed someone straight up. Okay.
Try it, try it at home.
Go right with some random word automobile and then trace over it.
You've off you get this insane urge. Overwhelming urge this blood lust. Okay.
And this girl is sitting there 1 million followers over and so
also crying doing it.
Hey, your dad died early.
So you got probs. All right.
But she's happy. She's got a million being happy to get. Look. That's great.
Okay. So crying because I wanted it so bad.
I can't even express how grateful I am to have so much love and support from all
of you. Well, that's honky, Dory. Nobody gives a.
That's for sure.
If you think your followers are honestly supporting you and loving you,
Hey, go home,
go on a retreat somewhere. Okay?
I want you guys to know that if it just gets better and better,
I want you guys to know that if you have a dream,
heck don't ever let someone tell you that you can't do it. By the way,
what thinks that a hot girl can't get 1 million followers.
I'm surprised that all girls don't have 1 million followers.
I'm surprised there isn't a girl that looks like that guy from the Goonies,
with the bent ear, that doesn't have a hundred that has a million followers.
Because if you're a girl, you can get as many followers as you want.
If you're showing your back door,
all you gotta do is open up your back door and follow her.
So why
fo inspirational. Why wouldn't you don't ever listen.
I want to tell you that you can't do it. Why wouldn't you be able to? Well,
I don't know. I mean actually, you know what the answer to that is?
Tons of reasons there are. Yeah.
Why can't you do the thing you want to do? Well,
it's like the, the lady at church grits, potatoes mash, BAMS pants.
You can just do a big song about it.
Why can't you do the thing you want to graze potatoes, mass, mass camps.
But with just like family money, buggin stress, anxiety disorders,
kids pass fast.
Why can't you do it? No talent, family, stress kids,
you know, anxiety. Um,
why wouldn't you be able to, you are the only one stopping yourself.
Oh yeah. Cops,
family, kids, France. People pretend the lack of they don't.
Um, for all we know, this is our only life.
So why would you ever let someone else's words and perspective stop you from
being happy and doing what you're drawn to do in the end. It's you?
And it's your life. You're stuck with yourself.
You die so long story short.
Do what makes you happy and thank you all so,
so much for being with me on this journey. I love you.
There's no journey, dude.
You're in a leopard print dress showing your.
That's not a journey. Everyone thinks they're on a journey. You know?
Oh, you know, it's the juror. It's um, the jury, you know, people don't,
it's not about the end result. It's about the journey then.
Why is everyone always a busted nut? Huh? Who does that?
Who? Doesn't bust a nut. Who does that?
Weird.
It's about the journey. You know,
it's not about particularly getting to where you're going.
It's about what you learn about. All right.
Sensei red belt on the outta here.
tans, clamps, BAMS, dude. This chick just no clue.
Here's the thing too is a young woman. She's 20 or something.
Or even if she's 19 or 1800. Okay.
It's tough because you gotta, you got to understand that
this is not sustainable.
You're going to the second you turned 35 immediate tears
because guys, aren't going to be paying attention to it in that way.
Like they used to, it's a sad truth.
But um, it's true.
Why wouldn't someone? Why wouldn't someone? Why wouldn't you be able to family,
kids, anxiety, age disease.
I just, you know,
what's crazy is we don't know the long-terms effect of social media.
Like that woman is going to be 51 day.
That's how she grew up. When she was 12. Instagram was the thing. This is,
she thinks these followers love her dude.
Have you ever heard Snoop dog?
When I love these hoes, I'm out the dough.
They don't love you. Listen to Snoop dog, dude.
We don't learn them. How is the at the dough? Hey dude,
you think your followers love you for posting your rump.
Have you ever heard this?
[inaudible] act like y'all know. It's the abominable whole man
international post. Hey Dick dope.
Man. I have you ever heard of him?
Of the neighbor, Dick dope, man.
They don't love you. They squirt TIAA.
I mean do it. It's just unreal. What's up with the parents, man.
Get involved here, dude.
If I have a daughter and she's posting her rump on Instagram,
guess what's happening. Guess what's happening.
I am a locking her in a room for a week straight.
All she's eaten is you potatoes man pants.
And this is what she's listening to over and over again.
Two Oh two that's in small cities and States. Oh matter of fact,
three Oh five. We can meet outside.
Control your hormones and keep your drawers on. So.
Creative. We control the hormones and traits the or doors,
area, area code.
Why did ludicrous always dress like Gilligan?
Dude. Ludicrous is Gilligan from Gilligan's Island. Dude,
man TV shows used to be lit, huh? Gillig.
I used to watch it with my grandma Gilligan's Island.
Oh the minimum from phone. But I'm pumped from minimum.
Just chick showing her, rubbing him nothing.
[Inaudible] imagine these guys singing this and then directly getting all the.
[inaudible] beat the living out of them. And they're like, what the?
And the kind of they're trying to block it. But the punch goes through the face,
through the hand and smacks in the face. The show bloody.
Get your kicked to the song
would be lost.
Sucks.
That's worth way worse than control your hormones and eat some hor
d'oeuvres God, that song sucks.
Brown. Let us show it up. This son, Charlie desert.
Oh, shut up. You, you know,
um,